i love that this job left me no excuse
but to be shown something and i would be
able to pick up on it quickly
the new die hard or should we say
hawkeye tv show is freaking awesome if
you haven't seen it yet trust a bro
you're going to want to and then come
back here and watch this video we're
going behind the scenes to see if making
it was just as fun as watching it let's
check it out
listen i i was grateful to be able to
explore this
this part of her life
number one to
barton's displeasure
hailey steinfeld was the only actress
anyone had even considered for the role
of kate bishop when she went to meet the
execs she recalls it being the most
intense surreal situation by the sounds
of it it felt a lot like entering the
avengers complex due to the secret back
elevators
number two
this dynamic duo can't be beat
the character dynamics in the show are a
huge part of what will make hawkeye a
success or a flop the goal was to give
the show a classic buddy cop energy the
banter between the two leads renner and
steinfeld came pretty naturally and the
chemistry between them was lightning
supposedly collaborating with jeremy
requires a lot more strength than i
think it looks like it might runner
agrees a lot of course they say that but
you can see the love
number three it's godfathers it's pizza
pizza wait it's pizza dog as much as
we'd love to say the story of pizza dog
is similar to how they found [ __ ] from
that live-action lady in the [ __ ] that
just isn't the case but you'll be happy
to know that means that his missing
eyeball is totally cgi did somebody say
ball
this pupper goes by the name of jolt and
while jolt was a very good boy hailey
steinfeld found herself struggling to
juggle all her props and the dog when he
got his eyes on a squirrel
very fun
very tricky
number four and marvel is coming around
to it as we are now well into phase four
of the marvel cinematic universe it has
been absolutely thrilling to see the
inclusivity marvel is bringing to the
table and with that comes clint barton's
deafness from standing just a bit too
close to one too many explosions
yeah just
hey we're communicating but what excites
us even more is the deaf indigenous
actress alaqua cox who is also kicking
butt with a prosthetic leg by the way
she recalls hearing she got the role
when she was invited to a zoom chat
seeing about 12 people including the
marvel studios president kevin feige
doing the death clap and they all said
to her welcome to the marvel family
despite her villainous entrance in the
show we're sure she's going to turn out
to be one of the good guys given the
spin-off that's on its way
we're free from limitations and it feels
i feel really fortunate to be a part of
this
number five and tony award for best
musical goes to
rogers the musical was just going to be
an easter egg on the side of a bus but
became the whole reason hawkeye came to
new york in the end
this idea to turn the musical into an
actual scene in the show was almost
backtracked when the director realized
that would mean needing a score written
a set built broadway actors brought in
and a whole choreography movement
planned film people are much more
comfortable making vans explode than
planning
[Music]
theater number six
all you need is a cool car two people
and a whole bunch of bad guys chasing
you
steinfeld couldn't contain her giggles
she was thrilled to be doing a car chase
sequence she says the whole thing felt
like a ride because it wasn't done with
a bunch of editing the main angle of the
scene was done in one shot with a camera
sitting between the two of them she
remembers it only taking about three
minutes to do the whole loop in one take
it's not a typical way to shoot a a car
chase sequence
number seven
[Music]
did you catch that larper dressed in the
og hawkeye costume guess barton's more
famous than he thought having a very
grounded character like hawkeye amongst
larpers it's a really really funny scene
this scene was done to mirror runner's
real-life interactions with marvel fans
but was also a low stakes and fun sort
of way for barton to get the costume
back the straight man character really
only works if everything around him is
larger than life
number eight at least one person has
called her the world's greatest archer
once steinfeld found out she'd got the
role she immediately started youtubing
everything she could about archery she
was concerned she'd need to be a master
archer for filming but jeremy destroyed
the magic for her when he told her that
the arrows are all cgi we guess that
kind of makes sense because if you're
going to shoot an arrow it's got to go
somewhere right nevertheless steinfeld
did end up training in archery for the
role so she isn't a total noob with a
bow yeah i'm good and also that
youtubing didn't come in handy at all
apparently her form was pretty darn
awful the first time she actually picked
up a bow and arrow
it's quite quite a thing to take on this
child is more professional than half of
hollywood
clara the actress who played young kate
bishop cut her foot while filming the
opening sequence of episode 1 and didn't
tell anyone until after she was finished
the shot she sat down quietly and
revealed it to the director she asked
was that okay concerned she'd wrecked it
that's the shot they chose for the show
so yes it was more than okay they had a
very limited amount of time to get the
shot too and so they only filmed it like
seven or eight times
mommy
mommy what's happening
maybe we'll end up with a snyder type
cut of avengers one day for the first
shot of hawkeye in the tv show old
footage from the 2012 avengers the
battle of new york was used they pulled
different angles of the same shot that
never happened to be used in the
original movie and blended them in with
some new shots the best archers in the
mcu are one-shot wonders on camera as
well
slow-mo falling into the water shot we
did that one time steinfeld was nervous
leading up to it because timing was
super important she had to remind
herself i have to start running with my
right foot otherwise it's all gonna be
messed up she found it a fun shot but
alas when you're as good as the actors
in this show you don't need second takes
or stunt doubles in this case we're not
talking about a straight to tv movie
here early on there was a conversation
about whether hawkeye would be a movie
or a tv show renner was glad to get the
six episodes to flesh out his character
i know what happened i was there
we knew it wasn't there
it's that guy due to chaotic schedules
they had to film the show more like a
movie with scenes from different
episodes shot on the same day do we
really need another superhero story set
in new york hawkeye was mostly filmed in
the big apple between thanksgiving and
christmas of 2020. runner founded a very
weird experience due to the pandemic it
was just kind of weird not having the
energy of the people a strong setting is
more than just a location it is a
character in our show
director rhys thomas echoes the
sentiment and adds that one of his
biggest pet peeves is fake geography in
movies i felt a pride
in in revisiting the city through this
mcu lens of course new york is a huge
part of marvel due to creator stan lee
growing up and setting up shop there
write what you know
we were pretty gleeful it was pretty
pure joy
from musical numbers to car chases
hawkeye seems to have a little bit of
something for everyone musical numbers
to car chases hawkeye seems to have a
little bit of something for everyone
it's the santa claus of tv shows and
it's nicey the cast so jolly too but
what we're wondering is if there was a
real avengers musical would you check it
out love the idea or hate it let us know
in the comments thanks for watching
[Music]